good morning Hank it's Tuesday I don't
really want to make a video today but
it's Tuesday so hey when we were growing
up in Orlando Florida it always felt to
me like we were all just visiting like
we were all just there for the theme
parks whether to visit them or work in
them and even today when people ask me
where I'm from I usually say Alabama
even though I didn't move there until I
was 14 for a long time I believed it
because I never felt fully at home in
Orlando that no one else could either
but of course that's just narcissism in
the 24 years since I've left Orlando has
become a great city people have made it
an awesome hometown by growing deep
roots there including a strong Latino
community and a vibrant LGBTQ community
both of which have achieved so much with
love and activism in the face of a long
history of violence and discrimination
and now 49 people killed in a gay club
in Orlando I don't know Hank I don't
know what to say I don't know if I have
anything constructive to say I do think
it's valuable to listen to people who've
been directly affected by the shootings
in Orlando I've put some reading in the
doobly-doo I would particularly move by
the partner of Leroy Valentin Fernandez
who wrote you will always be my baby and
I will always love you and by the
brother of victim Amanda all they are
who said she wouldn't want anyone to
spread hate for her she would want them
to spread more love and by victim will
Lisa Wilson Leone's friend Daniel who
said he'd been dealing with hate all his
life we all have I have he never
retaliated with hate aside from that
Hank I really just want to share with
you the names of the people who were
murdered I think we should hear their
names as much as possible
last night Orlando showed what a great
city it is when thousands of people came
out to memorialize the dead and to stand
with their friends and families let us
also stand with them by listening to
them by listening to those who loved
them and by remembering them Edward
Sotomayor jr. Stanley a motive are the
third Luis Omar Acacio capo Eric Yvonne
Ortiz Rivera Peter Ami
Juan Ramon Guerrero Lewis V Elma
Kimberly Morris
Eddie justice Daryl Roman Burt the
second D Anka Dedra Drayton Alejandro
Barrios Martinez Anthony Lewis Laureano
della Jean Carlos Mendes pirates Frankie
Jimmy
- hey Suz Velasquez Amanda all day honor
Martin Benitez Torres Luis Daniel Wilson
Lyon Merced is Marisol Flores Javier
Manuel Serrano Rosato Gilberto Ramon
Silva Menendez Simone Adrian Carillo
Fernandez Oscar era Senna Montero
Enrique Rios jr. Miguel on a hill
Onorato Javier Jorge Reyes yo al rayyan
Paniagua Jason Benjamin Josaphat Cori
James Connell Juan Rivera Velasquez Luis
Daniel Conde Shane Evan Tomlinson Juan
Shiva's Martinez Gerald Arthur right
Kevin Eugene Crosby Leroy Valentin
Fernandez Jonathan Antonio komoi Vega
John Nivas Rodriguez Rodolfo Ayala
Ayala Brenda Lee Marquez McCool Akira
Monet Marie you Marie
Rodriguez Sullivan Christopher Andrew
line onin on hell candelario pondrá
Frank Hernandez Paul Terrell Henry
Antonio de von Braun Christopher Joseph
San Felice